why
so one of the most requested things
after the Infinity Gauntlet here on my
youtube channel was the age of Ultron
and this makes sense because next year
Avengers 2 age of Ultron comes out now
the one thing you guys also need to keep
in mind is that Avengers 2 age of Ultron
is only using the name it's not going to
be based around the story of the age of
Ultron for a few reasons one because the
age of Ultron story largely revolves
around the actions of Susan storm and
Wolverine neither of which Marvel has
the right rights to within the realm of
making movies now one thing I'd like you
guys to pay attention to as we're going
through this story is that the age of
Ultron in a lot of ways is very
reminiscent to the Days of Future past
and the reason for this is because if
you recall our discussion about Days of
Future past we had talked about how it
was a landmark story when it first came
out and it was it was a huge deal one of
the reasons why it was such a big deal
was because it gave to us this idea of a
very dark and dystopian future a very
bleak outlook which is something we
hadn't really seen before with the
crooked world in Marvel UK we had kind
of delved into alternate realities but
we hadn't really seen anything on the
scale of what we saw with the Days of
Future past and so we had talked about
how that story would influence other
stories for generations to come and the
age of Ultron is a perfect example of
that now as we get into the age of
Ultron story we're actually following
Hawkeye and initially we don't realize
it's him all we know is that in the torn
down derelict city of New York that
somebody is following what appears to be
a woman of the night as she's moving
towards an apartment building of some
kind and what we see going on here is
that it appears a few individuals have
noticed her and they ask her what it is
that she's doing here and Hawkeye takes
this time.this a moment in which they're
distracted to attack them to kill both
of the guards using his precision aim
and his arrows now this is a very big
moment for Hawkeye not necessarily
because he's killing these guards but
because we start the story off with
Hawkeye Hawkeye and Marvel Comics had
largely been relegated to a background
character one of the more notable
stories involving him was the House of M
and Avengers disassembled but again this
is one of the first times that we
actually see Hawkeye being broken out as
a main stage character within a Marvel
storyline and what we see is that after
these individuals these two guards are
killed that Hawkeye breaks into the
building and systematically begins
killing everybody in it and again this
is interesting here because despite the
fact that Hawkeye never really had top
billing in Marvel Comics he had always
presented himself as a person that
wasn't without mercy but it seems as
though that in this story he is that he
is cold and calculating and isn't giving
anybody a chance to escape what we also
see are a couple interesting villains
here the villain and the green jacket is
owl and the one in the gray shirt is
amber head now owl is a very interesting
villain here because he's largely a
daredevil villain and so for us to see
him in this story indicates that
whatever it is it's taking place is not
confined to any one superhero is not
confined to any one super villain
instead it's a massive crossover event
and so as we continue we see that
Hawkeye is continuing to go through and
to kill virtually anybody who opposes
him at this point we learned that the
whole reason why Hawkeye was here the
whole reason why he came to this
building is because spider-man is being
held captive here and his goal is to
attempt to free spider-man which of
course he's able to successfully do but
it seems as though Peter Parker has been
held drugged up he has been more or less
held unconscious so he's not fully of
woolly aware of what's going on here or
fully um I guess in control of his
physical capabilities and so as Hawkeye
and spider-man are attempting to flee
the building there's some sort of
massive shake some kind of maybe massive
explosion outside we're not really sure
what it is but the entire building is
shaking all around them and what we
learn here is that several Ultron robots
have descended from the massive machine
hovering above New York down into the
apartment below and again this is very
reminiscent of the Days of Future past
in the sense that we saw sentinels which
were procreating themselves more or less
maintaining this element of control of
society around them and the Ultron
robots tell everybody within
the apartment building that they have to
leave immediately that they need to exit
but what we'll see as this story
progresses is that this isn't
necessarily what the Ultron robots
intend they're not really telling these
people to exit it's simply maybe a
virtue of their programming and what we
learn is that while a countdown is given
the Ultron robots almost immediately
destroy the entire apartment building
but not before Hawkeye and spider-man
are able to escape now Hawkeye and
spider-man initially on behalf of
Hawkeye do does what he can to destroy
these Ultron robots that he manages to
take out a couple of them but then we
learn why it is that spider-man was
being held here now this will become
very important when we get into the
second issue of age of Ultron but what
al tells us is that there was some kind
of an agreement worked out between
himself and these Ultron robots and the
agreement was that as long as the owl
and his forces kept delivering
superheroes or super-powered beings to
Ultron and his forces the forces would
leave him alone
but these Ultron robots largely seem to
ignore this and they continue their
destruction of the apartment building
now from here we follow a Hawkeye and
spider-man as they attempt to go
underground below Central Park through
the sewer system but almost immediately
after they arrive in the end underground
in the sewer system they're ambushed by
Luke Cage and she-hulk and Luke Cage
tells us or tells Clint Barton that he
was told not to return that when he said
he was going to leave that he needed to
stay gone
but Hawkeye says that his entire
motivation here was to rescue spider-man
to bring spider-man back now at the
moment we don't know why it was he had
went on a mission to retrieve spider-man
if perhaps there was some greater
motivation behind it or if it was simply
something his basic that's just trying
to reclaim a superhero that had been
captured but we see that for the most
part he feels justified in his actions
that he doesn't regret leaving the
safety or the relative safety of this
underground bunker to travel and try to
gain spider-man but then we see that
Tony Stark arrives and she hoped tells
Tony Stark to do whatever is it he needs
to do and we see the Tony Stark has some
kind of device with him now initially
Tony Stark doesn't want to use any kind
technology out in the open then most
likely this is due to the fact that
Ultron is able to detect the use of
technology somewhere in the city we're
not entirely sure but that would seem to
be the most likely reason but we see
that whenever this device is a Tony
Stark uses is apparently able to detect
whether or not individuals who have
arrived here have some kind of bug
planted in them by Ultron or if they're
even in Ultron robot itself but the
device is able to verify that both
Hawkeye and spider-man are in fact human
and they don't have any kind of tracking
devices implanted in them at this point
we transition to what appears to be a
makeshift barracks and within this
makeshift barracks there are various
superheroes who are holding up and it
seems as though maybe they're organizing
maybe they're trying to form a plan but
as the conversation progresses between
Hawkeye and Iron Man we learn that there
is no plan that there really is no idea
here in terms of what the next step
should be and that the reason why is
because the one person they're counting
on to help them make a plan the one
person they're counting on to help them
figure out what they should do next is
huddled in a corner crying with Captain
America shield completely shattered with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace